[Musica]
[Applauso]
l'anno scorso ho deciso di cambiare
lavoro ormai da manager a poppa full
time
nella mia giornata sono scomparse
presentazioni riunioni nei pranzi cene
viaggi di lavoro e di piacere che sono
comparsi pannolini biberon barba incolta
notti insonni vestiti sporchi ma anche
tempo per risolvere sono sopravvissuto e
ad oggi è stato uno dei più grandi
orgoglio dalla mia carina questa sera
voglio condividere con voi due semplici
riflessioni
ciao marco lato in questo per la prima e
l'importanza di godersi la vita senza
rimpianti anche andando contro gli
stessi che ci sono quando mia moglie è
rimasta in ternani fare i nostri gemelli
carlo e luca ho subito capito che volevo
spendere tempo con loro e che ce lo
sarebbe stato difficile distonia lavoro
allora ho cominciato a parlarle case
suoi amici e ho scoperto che in realtà
c'è una possibilità previsto per tutti i
lavoratori dipendenti quelle del congedo
parentale facoltativo che sono sei mesi
parzialmente alle prime liti con toppo e
il 5 mesi di maternità obbligatoria
palermo che possono prendere giunto in
un padre o la madre e io conoscevo
perché sì ma doni che avevano usufruito
di questa opportunità erano state a casa
un periodo ma nessun uomo e quindi qui
intesa forse no per me il primo
stereotipo il primo aspetto della
cultura in cui c'è una legge ma io ad
esempio non la conoscete e credo che
alcuni anche perché
ci pensa sempre che l'uomo che lavora
invece la donna si deve preoccupare le
scegliere della e dopo il periodo no di
materne partecipe obbligatorio e 5 mesi
se la donna torna in ufficio a volte
addirittura viene venerata vista male
non era una brava madre mette la
carriera prima della famiglia mentre del
padre insiste non è un caso se prendere
qualche giorno già sembra un eccezione
ma perché va dalla madre sia genitori
entrambi però evidentemente due pesi due
misure di come la gente
il nuovo vissuto in prima persona nelle
reazioni delle persone quando ho
cominciato a parlare di questa idea
stroma maturani punto non ho da
relazioni molto forti ma sei matto
chissà questo che succede col lavoro
quando torni cosa penseranno gli altri
di tre della sua carriera o anche
reazioni diciamo così di forza nvidia
lettera mogli uomini ci dicevano ha
sibrato tenete lo fa io non ho potuto
fare
erano le relazioni con le più importanti
e genuini e che io sono arrivato dalle
donne amiche e colleghe che sono rimaste
scioccate una retta ma migliore positivo
perché hanno realizzato che c'è la
grande raggiunge i tuoi sogni mentre in
chiaro quali sono le tue priorità
soprattutto una in particolare reazione
è stata quella facendolo tu lo posso
fare anch'io da il permesso di farla ca
allora ne ho capito e se ho la
possibilità di fare una cosa va la
positiva prova e al contempo dà anche la
possibilità almeno un'altra persona di
fare altrettanto
quel punto non c'è prima che bisogna
anche bisogna farlo ho pensato che
questa scelta penalizzasse la mia
carriera che se avere insomma
dismessa ri sta male finisce fuori sì mi
sono lasciato influenzare ma questo non
è affatto cambiato idea no alla fine ho
pensato che amica la page nuovo lavoro
si può trovare chissà quanti lavori
cambieremo nei prossimi decenni che
dobbiamo lavorare ma passare il primo
anno di vita che propri figli nel mio
caso o per restituire qualsiasi sogno
possa avere quello volte non si può
tornare in b e quindi non si deve farlo
su ed è questo che è certo è che è
lasciati dai appunto l'importanza di
vivere senza rimpianti per cogliere
l'opportunità il secondo messaggio
voglio passare è quello di godersi il
tempo quando abbiamo deciso di prendere
questo periodo lungo una moglie abbiamo
deciso di lasciare milano e quindi
passare un periodo liguri dove un
periodo dove la famiglia noi che siamo
imbarcati su il primo aereo per i nostri
figli questo milano taipei di a
singapore carichi di bagagli e di
aspettative
le aspettative erano lo vediamo nella
prossima slide tra quelle di colazioni
rilassate prevedendo giornali hanno
anche i bambini dormivano a passeggiate
insieme con qui a fare più sport lager
libri che ho letto prima pensare al
futuro
voleremo fa si è rilevata un po diverso
immerso a stabilire che urlavano
insuccessi vari tra cui questi quando
prova invocare il mio figlio per la
prima volta invece dalla pasta al sugo è
diventato la facciamo al sugo o non
travolta in cui ho messo le scarpe al
contrario
il figlio luca o più giorni potevamo a
visitare nella sua ciano appena arrivati
ci ha vestito questo bambini che sono io
sto imparando il nuovo lavoro perché il
nuovo lavoro si tratta e non è
importante farlo bene in questo caso è
senz'altro appunto fatto anche ma
importante esserci al cento per cento
capire quant'è duro impegnativo il
lavoro di crescere
e difficile e quindi penso che questo
non ritornerà in futuro essere migliore
padre perché conosco meglio ma anche il
migliore marito spiega perché so
l'impegno allo spazio mentale energia
fisica che è certo per questo quindi
rispetto per supportare mia moglie nelle
scelte personali e professionali che
vogliamo
gli stormi troviamo raggiunge mascherone
anche nel paese non miglior manager
uffici con le mani esempio il futuro per
capire come supportare loro a cambiare e
provare a combinarle e succulenti loro i
loro duetti ho capito quindi cioè tavolo
e ne importa il come dicevo farlo farlo
cremona importante dedicare il 100 per
cento della propria attenzione focus
perché così gli ci riesci a guardare e
questo è con questo il messaggio per
questa sera per tutti in questo punto di
importanza di godersi la lingua senza
rimpianti prestabili bisogna sapersi
godere il tempo cogliere le opportunità
magari facendo per primi qualcosa così
non ci saranno gli ultimi a parte a lei
la somma è qui l'invito a voi per questa
sera se volete
pensate a una cosa un desiderio che
avete un sogno nel cassetto
come avete avuto il coraggio di troppo
bene
provate a tirarlo fuori parlatene
famiglia alla loro c'è dentro supporto e
se capita l'opportunità fatela lanciato
sarebbe un regalo voi stessi e magari la
fortuna grazie